roth geht ihr momentan wirklich gar
nicht oder hier haben wir also im moment
wirklich keinen guten lauf und claudia
roth manches claudia
[Musik]
hier in dieser halle findet der
parteitag der grünen stadt ja noch ist
es relativ leer
insider vermuten dass der ein oder
andere grüne noch in gorleben angekettet
ist es läuft ja ich hätte es die heute
show ja ok lieblingssendung von amazon
ist er ehrlich
zusammen mit geben von mir ich kann ich
bin ja anders und die heute show
darf man als vip bekommen zieht ihn hat
richtig bock im statement abzugeben
leider viele komplett andere sendung von
künast
darf ich ihnen zwei drei fragen stellen
also ok noch leben wir dass unsere
generation lebt auf kosten der
nachfolge-generation und wir leben hier
auf kosten der der dritten welt die wir
deutschen ja aber funktioniert doch
leider erwarten wir
[Musik]
aber das ist ja genial das system wenn
man sich so überlegen aber für die
minderheit aber das wollen wir ändern
oder was natürlich ist doch gut
ja leider aber auch aus koblenz auf
wessen kosten geht uns gut wir auch auf
kosten der anderen klar
mal
[Musik]
roth geht ihr momentan wirklich gar
nicht oder wir haben also im moment
wirklich keinen guten darauf und claudia
roth manche schon claudia wenn sie jetzt
regieren werden die minister ämter
erneut verteilt wer wird zum beispiel
verteidigungsminister claudia roth also
es wird eine frau aber es ist noch zu
früh über die namen können ja ins ohr
flüstern ich sage auch nichts weiter als
wir von der presse sehr vertrauenswürdig
ich sag nix ok journalist könnten
natürlich in frage kommen als
regierungssprecher
dabei will er nicht so schnell ab
regierungssprecher muss man natürlich
nicht nur nadelstreifen haben daran
hängt oben zu nach reisekoffer immer
bereit
wir sehen ja was denn da reizt den wir
rocken das klingt ja das war vom
parteitag der grünen das war mein
letzter beitrag für die heute show denn
ich bin ja jetzt fest sprecher bei den
grünen
die bezahlung ist
[Applaus]